- [Narrator] This, true
believers, is a tale
where two storied parts of
American culture come together.
It truly was a unicorn moment.
Join us as we open the vault
of automobile and film history.
(dramatic music)
(coughing)
This is the story of Florence Lawrence.
She was a full-blown star
of the silent film era.
And, she's also the
inventor of the turn signal.
Florence starred in over 300 films
produced by Biograph Studios.
Her success led to a bit of wealth,
which she used to buy a car.
A crazy expensive purchase at the time.
It was love at first drive.
Florence went from casual user
to automotive expert,
pursuing a knowledge
and expertise about cars
that outstripped even
her passion for acting.
She invented features
to make driving safer
and more enjoyable.
In 1914 she created a
signaling arm for cars
that would allow drivers to indicate
when they wanted to turn.
Push a button, and her
invention raised a flag
on the bumper saying left or right.
It was a great idea,
but sadly Florence never
registered her design.
Versions of it popped up,
but it was another 10 years
before the turn signal was patented.
And unfortunately, by somebody else.
And that's when things
took a turn for the worse.
She lost most of her wealth
in the stock market crash of 1929
and was injured in a fire on set.
She never recovered her earlier success.
Once the biggest movie star in the world,
now all but forgotten.
But the fact remains: she was a pioneer
both as an actor and as a car enthusiast.
And even as she fades from memory,
her contribution to cars remains.
(gentle music)
(logo dinging)